und was passiert gerade eigentlich auf
den flüchtlingsrouten hier nach
Deutschland unsere BILD-Reporter die
waren jetzt tatsächlich mit der
Bundespolizei gemeinsam unterwegs 24
Stunden lang in der Nacht auf der Suche
nach kriminellen Schleusern und dann das
ein Auto sie sehen es hier ein kleiner
Renault vollgepackt mit Flüchtlingen
zusammengepfercht ja eben auf der Suche
nach dem großen Glück hier in
Deutschland
Schockmoment in Frankfurt an der Oder im
Kofferraum eines kleinen Autos findet
die Polizei 7 Ägypter am Steuer ein
ukrainischer Schleuser
kein Einzelfall erst vor wenigen Tagen
befinden sich in Bayern 16 Menschen
darunter neun Kinder das jüngste zwei
Jahre alt in einem Kleinlaster täglich
kommen mehr Flüchtlinge und Migranten
aus Syrien Afghanistan Ägypten dem Iran
und Irak illegal über die
deutsch-polnische Grenze in Brandenburg
werden im September 814 unerlaubte
einreisen registriert im August waren es
noch 5009 die Menschen kommen illegal
nach Deutschland um hier ihr Glück zu
finden oft zu Fuß zusammengefährcht den
Koffer Räumen wie vier auf Ladeflächen
oder in luftdichten kühltransportern die
Szenen erinnern stark an 2015 auch
damals bringen skrupellose Schleuser
viele Menschen nach Deutschland für ihre
Arbeit kassieren die Kriminellen oft
Tausende von Euro pro Migranten der
österreichische Innenminister Gerhard
Karner kommt zum flüchtlingsgipfel von
Bild nach Berlin er spricht von einem
notwendigen Kampf gegen die
schleppermafia
ungefähr agiert unglaublich brutal
Menschenleben spielen hier keine Rolle
wir sehen fast wöchentlich Unfälle wo
Schlepper mit ihren potenziellen Kunden
verunglückenweise vor der Polizei
fliehen weil sie vor den Kontrollen
fliehen wir haben alleine in Österreich
in den ersten der ersten Hälfte dieses
Jahres oder erst nach Monaten über 480
schlepperfest genommen die hier mit
illegalen Migranten unterwegs waren alle
Nationen betrifft das das ist ein
internationaler
mafia-konzern der mittlerweile mehr
verdient als im Drogenhandel und daher
ist es notwendig dass die Europäische
Union die Kommission aber auch die
Mitgliedsländer diesen Kampf ganz stark
führt im Fall der Ägypter hat keiner
Papiere bei sich die Polizei bringt sie
schließlich in ein erstaufnahmelager bei
Eisenhüttenstadt für die Polizisten ist
damit der Job erledigt doch schon morgen
werden sie wieder auf der Autobahn
unterwegs sein
sieben Flüchtlinge eingepfercht in einem
Transporter wir wollen darüber sprechen
mit Heiko tega von der deutschen Polizei
Gewerkschaft Herr tegarts welche neuen
Tricks lassen sich die Schleuse jetzt
noch alles einfallen
lassen sich alle möglichen Tricks
einfallen und wir rennen als Polizei
oftmals den Tricks auch nur hinterher
also es beginnt mit der Auswahl der
Routen wie die Migranten nach Europa und
Deutschland gebracht werden und das
endet letztendlich mit der
Transportmöglichkeit sie hat es ja
angesprochen alle haben die Bilder noch
im Auge mit den mehr als 80 Toten
Migranten in diesem luftdichten
Kühllaster und hier muss hier muss
gehandelt werden wir brauchen ein
konsequenten europäischen
außengrenzschutz und vor allem müssen
wir es tunlichst unterlassen
weitere poolfaktoren zu schaffen die die
Menschen immer wieder neu animieren in
ihrer Heimat alles aufzugeben ihr
letztes Hab und Gut an die
schleppermafia zu zahlen um dann den
gefährlichen Weg nach Europa und
Deutschland anzutreten können wir gleich
noch mal sprechen über diese
pull-faktoren Herr tega aber wir sehen
diese Fotos noch mal das sind alles
frische Fotos alles aus den letzten
Tagen und ja für 14 Tage ungefähr sind
diese Bilder maximal Alter aus den
Lastern alles zusammengefert zig
Flüchtlinge da reingefährt vor allen
Dingen in Bayern und eben in Frankfurt
oder jetzt dieses Foto da aus dem
Renault Tackers wir müssen uns ja nichts
vormachen die Menschen die haben sie da
aufgegriffen auf der Autobahn aber die
bleiben ja bei uns
ja selbstverständlich bleiben die bei
uns weil uns ja auch komplett die
Möglichkeit genommen wird an der Grenze
zur Tschechischen Republik und na Polen
direkt an der Grenze stationär zu
kontrollieren in so einem Fall könnten
wir die die schlepperding festmachen wir
wissen wir wüssten wer nach Deutschland
einreißt und wir könnten das auch dann
dokumentieren für spätere Asylverfahren
aber das ist uns leider untersagt weil
politisch immer noch nicht die
Entscheidung gefallen ist die Grenze zur
Tschechischen Republik und auch die neue
Ausweichroute über Polen
einzuführen sie sind in dem Moment im
Grunde Lebensretter sie machen die
kofferraumtür auf und retten den
meistens ja Männern da das Leben aber
das hat nichts zu tun damit dass die
dann abgeschoben werden oder man sofort
die Schleuser dort abführt nein es geht
es geht wirklich um um Leben retten
selbst sie haben treffen formuliert weil
wer weiß wohin dieser Renault noch
weiter gefahren wäre ob Berlin oder oder
vielleicht Hamburg oder oder Frankfurt
keiner weiß es und die Zustände
schlichtweg unhaltbar für die Menschen
dort in diesem Auto ganz klar aber muss
sagen es war eben jetzt leider Gottes
muss man sagen nur ein Zufallsfund es
gibt keine Möglichkeit für sie
tatsächlich mal flächendeckend zu
kontrollieren und das heißt ja dann wohl
auch dass es fast unmöglich ist den
Schleusern irgendwie her zu werden oder
ja kein Mensch weiß auch genau wie hoch
die Dunkelziffer ist also wenn Sie die
die Zahlen die die Bundespolizei
feststellt im Rahmen ihrer ihrer
rasterverhandlung jetzt vergleichen mit
den Zahlen des bamfs die regelmäßig
veröffentlicht werden dann klappt da
eine sehr große Lücke und ich behaupte
dass nicht mal diese Zahlen die
Dunkelziffer überhaupt
widerspiegeln also wir haben da einen
kriminalitätsphänomen
Schwerstkriminalität
schlepperkriminalität
welches nicht konsequent genug politisch
angegangen wird
jetzt noch mal ganz schnell zu dem Pull
Faktoren diese immer Anfang des
Gesprächs genannt haben Herr terts ganz
konkret welchen pulfaktor sollten wir ja
abschaffen also zunächst einmal sollten
wir nicht Gesetze diskutieren oder gar
umsetzen die die den den Eindruck
erwecken jemand der mehrere Jahre in
Deutschland lebt auch in der Illegalität
lebt dessen Asylverfahren sozusagen
rechtskräftig abgeschlossen ist dann
dort ein dauerhaftes Bleiberecht
bekommen dieses Gesetz wird derzeit
gerade von der Ampel diskutiert und ich
kann nur dringend dazu raten dass in der
jetzigen Zeit nicht durchzusetzen weiter
ist es wichtig und ganz entscheidend
dass sich die europäischen
Nationalstaaten untereinander einig
werden einheitlichen Standard für die
Unterbringung der Menschen zu schaffen
solange der Standard für Unterbringung
in Deutschland höher ist als in anderen
europäischen Staaten müssen wir uns
nicht wundern dass die Menschen hier
hinkommen und eben nicht
gleichmäßig auf europäische Staaten
verteilt werden können all das sind
Faktoren natürlich auch die
schrecklichen Zustände in den
Heimatländern dieser Menschen die
schlichtweg animieren dazu nach Europa
und insbesondere nach Deutschland zu
kommen hier muss Politik
gemeinschaftlich europäische
gemeinschaftlich handeln
um diesem Schrecken ein Ende zu setzen
denn nur dann wenn der Anreiz Weg ist
macht man den Schlepperbanden auch das
Geschäft kaputt und das muss ja das Ziel
aller sein die Liste der Missstände ist
lang da muss viel getan werden danke
schön Heiko teggert gerne
[Musik]